Speaker 1: So listen, there is an investigation
into Joe Biden's son, Hunter Biden, that is
reportedly going on, and I really want to
speak to either the progressives in the audience
in the sense that for months, really almost
four years now, the right and Republicans
and the Trumpian right has been talking about
Hunter Biden's laptop, Hunter Biden's laptop,
Hunter Biden's criminality, Joe Biden's criminality
linked to Hunter Biden.
And we have taken each story one at a time
and each claim one at a time and said, Here
is the lies here is the lies, here is the
lies.
I've also said before that if Hunter Biden
maybe did something wrong, he should be investigated.
And unlike Donald Trump, Joe Biden shouldn't
try to interfere with that investigation.
Joe Biden shouldn't try to affect or influence
that investigation in any way.
And if Hunter Biden has committed a crime,
he should be charged, and if he is convicted,
he should be punished.
This is a very different perspective than
that of the Trumpian right, which is obfuscate,
obstruct, influence and try to affect legal
proceedings.
So we should be consistent, and that's exactly
what I'm going to be.
First of all, I'm not going to hide from you
that it now appears there is a federal investigation
into Hunter Biden.
Big report yesterday from CNN Federal investigation
of Hunter Biden heats up now it has nothing
to do with the laptop may be disappointing
to some Republicans in our audience.
CNN reports.
A Justice Department investigation into Hunter
Biden's business activities has gained steam
in recent months, with a flurry of witnesses
providing testimony to federal investigators
and more expected to provide interviews in
the coming weeks.
According to multiple sources familiar with
the matter.
OK, what are the origins or oranges of this
investigation?
Well, the probe, led by the U.S. attorney
in Wilmington, Delaware, began as early as
2018, and it concerns multiple financial and
business activities in foreign countries dating
to when Joe Biden was vice president.
Investigators have examined whether Hunter
Biden and some of his associates associates
violated money laundering, tax and foreign
lobbying laws, as well as firearm and other
regulations.
These are that's a serious investigation.
Hunter Biden has not been charged with any
crimes, has denied wrongdoing.
His father, President Joe Biden, is not being
investigated as part of the probe of his son's
business activities, according to sources
who have been briefed.
But the ongoing investigation has persistently
raised questions about the ethics and behavior
of the president's son and has fueled right
wing political attacks.
In 2019, then President Trump pressured Ukraine
to investigate the Bidens over Hunter's work
for Burisma, a Ukrainian energy company, eventually
leading to Trump's first impeachment.
So.
Guys, let's just allow this to happen.
Right, I mean, investigate.
Do whatever you need to do.
I don't care about Hunter Biden as in terms
of, you know, as a political program in terms
of political analysis.
Unlike Jared Kushner, unlike Ivanka Trump,
unlike so many of Trump's cronies, Hunter
has nothing to do with Joe Biden's administration.
Hunter has nothing to do with policy.
Hunter's not sitting in for the secretary
of state the way Ivanka was at the G20 or
whatever meeting it was.
I have no interest in defending Hunter Biden.
There is nothing linking Joe Biden to any
of this.
Hunter Biden is being investigated for things
he did as a private citizen.
If he did something wrong, then charge the
guy.
If you want to throw the book at him, throw
the book at him.
If he's found guilty of any crimes, we shouldn't
apply a different standard now at the same
time.
It's worth remembering that what's going on
with Hunter Biden reinforces that what appears
to be the Trump crime family should be investigated,
and we continue to wonder what's going on,
what's going on.
Manhattan investigators quitting because they
got the impression that even though they found
evidence of Trump felonies, not Trump's kids
Trump felonies, that no charges were forthcoming.
I told you on Monday or Tuesday that a federal
judge has indicated evidence should be provided
on the basis that it seems likely that Trump
committed felonies.
Merrick Garland seems to have absolutely no
interest in pursuing any of it.
So investigate Hunter, investigate Trump.
There's evidence of felonies.
Charge all of them.
Here's a quick report from CBS News about
this.
Speaker 2: Multiple sources tell CBS News
that the federal investigation into Hunter
Biden's business practices is broader than
previously known.
The probe is exploring whether the younger
Biden and his associates violated tax money
laundering and foreign lobbying laws.
Business records reviewed by CBS News and
documents released by Republicans in Congress
indicate multiple financial transactions involving
Hunter Biden, his firm and a Chinese energy
company called CFC.
Republicans allege the company is an arm of
the Chinese government.
Speaker 1: Investigate all of it.
So let's be consistent, guys.
Let's be consistent.
Everybody who has who is suspected of wrongdoing
should be investigated.
If he's cleared, he will be cleared.
If he's not, he can be charged.
That's it.
And we need to remember when we talk about
the laptop claims and Rudy Giuliani's evidence
that he has in his den or whatever.
When it's wacky and cartoonish, we debunk
it.
Separately, there's an investigation going
on and it should and nobody should interfere
in it.
If you disagree with my perspective, let me
know you can find me on Twitter at David Pakman
and I'm glad to follow up on it.
The David Pakman Show is a community supported
independent media program I would love for
you to join the ranks of our supporters and
sign up at join Packman dot com.
You can not only now buy a membership, you
can gift a membership.
We currently have about 350 people who would
like a membership but cannot afford one.
And you can fulfill the dreams of as many
of those as those three hundred and fifty
people as you would like.
When you go through the signup process at
join Packman dot com, just click the box that
says this is a gift.
Leave the recipient blank and we will on a
first come, first serve basis, give that membership
to someone in need.
You can also request a
free membership at David Pakman dot com slash
free membership.
Very, very exciting stuff.